comment reprendre le fil de sa vie après
une agression cette question le docteur
Seb se la pose encore 6 mois maintenant
que ce dentiste tour en jeu a été
poignardé par un patience patient prix
d'une fureur incontrôlable il avait
confondu un doigtier en latex utilisé en
radiologie avec un préservatif la
victime et son avocat veulent
aujourd'hui un procès témoignage avec
Hélène chapelet
ça c'est une des blessures c'est comme
si c'était un tatouage qui va qui va
rester toute la vie
six mois après son agression ses plaies
sont désormais cicatrisés mais le
traumatisme lui est toujours là le
docteur janxseb n'a pas encore repris
son activité professionnelle il faut
dire que son cabinet dentaire était
inaccessible laissez-les poser n’ont été
enlevés que le 20 mars dernier
dernièrement le praticien franchit un
nouveau cap il est retourné sur son lieu
de travail là où il a reçu 10 coups de
couteau
mon psychiatre m'avait prévenu mais je
voulais pas croire et effectivement
quand je sors
quand je me rapproche de mon cabinet
quand je rentre dans l'entrée de
l'immeuble je oui j'ai une certaine
appréhension j'ai mon cœur qui bat une
fois que j'y suis puisque maintenant
j'ai été vendredi dernier
après vous dire j'ai eu les larmes aux
yeux quand je suis entré dans mon
cabinet ça m'a fait un petit choc
mais il va falloir que je m'y habitue
que de me
réapproprier les lieux et ça va se faire
petit à petit et j'espère reprendre
peut-être
dans quelques mois je ne sais pas
un autre combat attend également le
docteur Clem faire en sorte que son
agresseur réponde de ses actes devant la
justice aujourd'hui il vient faire le
point avec son avocat sur les suites de
son dossier après avoir passé quatre
mois en hôpital psychiatrique le mise en
cause est aujourd'hui placé en détention
provisoire à Orléans s'il est déclaré
pénalement irresponsable il pourrait ne
jamais y avoir de procès
n'est pas concevable pour le docteur Seb
et son assistante dentaire qu'il n'y ait
pas de procès donc nous allons être
particulièrement vigilant concernant les
expertises psychiatriques et si des
experts psychiatres ont des conclusions
qui nous semblent en Inde adéquation
avec la réalité du personnage bien
entendu nous aurons la possibilité de
demander des contre-expertises donc la
question ça abolition ou altération du
discernement qui dit abolition dit pas
de procès qui dit altération des procès
l'ancien patient du docteur Seb un
réfugié tchadien d'une quarantaine
d'années pour tentative d'assassinat
avec préméditation en cours la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité